this is one thing that a lot of
entrepreneurs never never never really
get what are you great at what do you
have the talent to be world-class at
what is it mix those you have a
successful company
what's that believe nation it's heaven
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have Michael Jordan
level talent at something and I want you
to find it embrace it and use it to make
a difference in the world so to help you
on your journey today we're going to
talk about the seven ways that you can
be a successful entrepreneur that work
enjoy now starting the business is
almost a recipe for disaster most people
don't make it whether you trust the 80%
or 90% whatever percentage it's a high
number people who never make it in
entrepreneurship and so I want to solve
that today I'm going to tell you the
seven different things that if you can
master you will really dramatically
improve your chances of winning as an
entrepreneur wait number one is look for
complaints most people love to complain
as human beings we love to complain you
will have to complain about the weather
the government taxes everything around
us we love to complain it's always
somebody else's fault
people don't like to take personal
responsibility or accountability for
this situation in life they want to
blame somebody else this is great news
for you as an entrepreneur if you can
listen to what people are complaining
about or listen to what you are
complaining about the opposite of every
complaint is a business the opposite of
every complaint is an opportunity that's
an idea ready for you to go off and
solve it when I started doing my top
tens I wanted to be around great people
who were doing great things and I can
never meet Steve Jobs and I didn't want
to have to listen through 40 hours of
footage of Steve Jobs talking about a
lot of stuff that wasn't relevant to me
I wish somebody put together a series of
his condensed information altogether so
that I could just consume it right
nobody did that so I did right I didn't
actually want to have to create my
channel I wish one of you guys did and I
could just consume it but because I was
facing this problem because a lot of you
guys are facing that problem too that
complaint turned into an opportunity so
you want to be looking at what are you
complaining about
what are people around complaining about
and how can you solve that don't think
of that as a problem anymore that is
your opportunity that is money that is
gold when people are complaining you get
happy because you can solve a problem
for them and they will pay you for it
[Music]
wait number two is match your passion
with the opportunity this is one thing
that a lot of entrepreneurs never never
never really get you will win when you
match what the opportunity is out there
with what you are passionate about if
you just love something but nobody else
wants it with you you have a hobby if I
just loved making top tens but none of
you guys ever enjoyed them I'd just be
watching them and making it for myself
it'd be a hobby which can be really
fulfilling make you feel good you made
something you created it you know you
can make a coffee table that you could
put your glasses on it doesn't mean
anybody else is ever gonna pay you for
but you can feel these sense of
accomplishment and having a hobby the
other side people just chase opportunity
you chase an opportunity all day long
trying to find out you know you open up
the magazine of ink and it shows you
what the hottest industries is start in
2018 2019 2020 are and you go off and do
that you will lose you will get
destroyed because the people who love
doing those things will always beat you
if you're just chasing the opportunity
and you are only in it for the money and
you don't actually have a passion for
that thing you lose if you try to come
and do top ten videos and you don't have
a passion for doing it you lose stop
losing stop doing the stuff that you
hate just try to chase an opportunity
you win when you combine those things
together what you love love-love-love
doing with what there is an opportunity
opportunity opportunity for mix those
you have a successful company
[Music]
way number three is keep momentum this
is always a tough one for entrepreneurs
this is one that really frustrates me
that I see every day in that you start
and you stop and you start and you stop
and you have a great day so much
momentum so much happening your mindset
is perfect you're thinking big and then
you wake up the next day and poof it's
gone it's like you're a different person
the energy the momentum the the level of
happiness is just is just gone you don't
want to do the work anymore and then
maybe next week you start up again and
you're all motivated again it's just
this constant roller coaster ride where
the people who win are the ones who are
consistent and so you need to figure out
what is the thing that gets you feeling
so motivated so pumped up so energetic
so alive so ready to go and take on the
day what is it is it watching the video
is it doing a meditation is it walking
your dog outside like whatever that
thing is that has to be a part of your
daily routine you need to keep the
momentum going
most people they quit too soon because
they let the momentum die where you
could have been great you could have
been great you could have built an
amazing business you could have built a
company for the ages you have genius
here and that could have been expressed
but you quit because you just couldn't
keep them want them going between the
days and so finding the thing to reverse
engineer yourself to know yourself to
know what gets you feeling pumped up and
then bringing that into your daily
routine to keep momentum going is
critical way number four is get a
customer just start talking a customer
sooner you're building maybe around your
own problem your own pain point but this
is a co-creation right when I'm talking
about matching the opportunity with what
you're passionate about
it's a co-creation you have to involve
your customers in the process and I want
you to start getting paid as quickly as
possible so many entrepreneurs or one of
the entrepreneurs are sitting at home -
sitting around the dining room table sit
in their home office and they're
constantly retooling rethinking new
ideas brainstorming filling sheets of
paper out with a list of all the things
that they're gonna do of ideas of
improvements and build in and build an
in tinkering and tinkering and never
actually releasing anything like making
money is a good thing it's not
everything but it's a good thing making
money allows you to build a team and
support yourself and get momentum going
and give you more encouragement and
expand to be able to reach more people
like it's important as soon as possible
if you can find a way to get a customer
on board who's willing to pay you
anything something just so that you have
momentum building it's really really
really really important stop spending
six months 12 months 24 months 36 months
18 years just sitting on an idea and
it's fun it's great to think about an
idea it's really nice to think about how
you get a problem solved in the future
right it's like working out this puzzle
in your head is really satisfying but
nothing actually happens until you build
something until you get it into somebody
else's hands and so firing a customer as
quickly as possible before it's ready to
go start talking to potential customers
and co-create with them every top 10
that I make has been requested by you
guys we're co-creating you're telling me
what you want and I'm making it I also
have to love it there's lots of top tens
you asked me to do that I don't do
because I don't I don't resonate with
any of the messages so I don't post it
up but everything that we make there's
thousands of top 10 requests you guys
want me to do it's that co-creation
so the faster you can get your customers
involved and the faster you get some
cash flow coming in the better it is for
you
[Music]
wait number five is know what your
talent is I start out these videos
saying I believe you have Michael Jordan
level talent it's something I do I
believe I believe you're a genius I
believe you have really strong talents
at something it's the Einstein quote
something around you know people think
they're stupid because they're a fish
trying to climb a tree right if that's
how you judge yourself as a fish the
ability to climb a tree you're gonna
lose all day long but if your fish you
swim like what are you great at what do
you have the talent to be world-class at
what is it because chances are it's not
what you're doing right now and you're
not spending enough time in your day and
what you could be world-class at you
know Michael Jordan should play
basketball when Michael Chen went to
baseball he didn't do so well if Michael
Jordan went to be an arborist if I
wouldn't do so well right there's like a
lot of career paths I would not fit
Michael Jordan he would be mediocre to
below average at tons of different jobs
but he found the one thing and that's
why we know his name through basketball
so then you need to find a thing that
you are great and then allocate as much
time as possible on that thing if you
know what your talents to that you know
what you could be the greatest in the
world at but you're only spending 5% of
your time doing it because you're
spending 95% of your time doing all the
other crap that's involved in running a
business then you want to really tighten
up focus down right as a one-man show
one-woman show you still have to do all
those other things but how do you
minimize them so you can spend as much
time as possible doing the thing that
you are great at because you will never
win doing stuff that you hate and that
you're not world-class at you will never
win doing stuff that you suck at so how
do you take that thing that you've
Michael Jordan level talent at and
moving from 5% of your time to 20% your
time to 40% in time to 50% of your time
the more time you spend doing that kind
of level talent work that's when
ultimately you will win
[Music]
way number six is to build a team just
recognizing that you can't do this alone
if you have a big vision for what you
want to do you want to have a big impact
you ultimately want to win the big game
as an entrepreneur you can't do it all
by yourself you may be multi-talented
you may have tons of skills and
experience but you can't do everything
yourself if I was still trying to make
every YouTube video myself man I'd be so
slow be making one video a week we're
now because of the team of eight people
that I have helping with my YouTube
videos we can make two to three a day
and I get the focus on the thing that I
love the most I get to focus on being in
front of the camera and not doing the
editing and not doing all the the
backend stuff that doesn't really
fulfill me and so building the team
allows you to go so much further and
listen I get if you're at the beginning
maybe you can't afford a team maybe you
can't afford to have somebody come on
board and that's great I hate spending
money till I'm making money I should be
like bonus rule don't spend money till
you're making money I hate doing that
but it's just a mindset that I want to
build a team I want to eventually have
people who are working for me I'm open
to that and then finding the smallest
possible way to get started the first
guy that I hired was for one hour a day
and that freed up an hour and a half of
my day to be able to do other work
because he was better at that thing that
I was so freed up more of my time and so
you don't also need to think I need to
hire somebody full-time you don't need
to wait until you have 40 50 60 K in the
bank so you can hire somebody full-time
you can do it right now for one hour a
day people will work for you for an hour
a day and it also it reduces your risk
because you will probably suck as a
manager at the beginning you might make
the wrong hire it might be a terrible
leader so you're not you don't have a
lot of financial exposure at the
beginning and also it allows you to
build up your skills it allows you to
learn how to be a leader allows you to
learn how to work with the team allows
you to learn how to push people and help
them get better which is a super
valuable skill to learn as an
entrepreneur and the sooner you get
going on it
the better so you need to have the
mindset of I want to build a team
[Music]
and way number seven is figure out your
one word at the top of everything is
gonna be your values the successful
people whether they use the one-word
methodology or something else they know
who they are and they know what they
stand for you have to know what your
most important core value is it's why I
wrote the book is why everything that
oozes believed from my channel always
does the best is how my channel explode
is because I really embrace believe
instead of trying to be a vanilla
version of everything else when you know
what you stand for you start living your
dreams instead of following the plans
that other people have for you and so
the core of all of that is
self-awareness I think a lot of people
feel like they could be doing more of
their life you know that there's an
extra gear you know that what you're
doing isn't necessarily playing
super-small your you might be even the
best amongst your friends you look
around and say hey I'm doing really well
but you know that there's another gear
you know that this is not the final
version you know that even right now
today there's a lot more that you could
be bringing than you are and you don't
know how to access it you don't know how
to unlock it it starts with your most
important core value it starts with
understanding what your one word is and
then bringing that to your business
bringing that to your life it's the
process to go through some people get it
quickly and some people takes a little
bit of time but I think it's the most
important exercise you can do in your
life because it gives you so much
clarity over everything that now you
must do and you can go super fast super
far when you have the compass and a map
to help take you there so that's my take
on the seven ways to become a successful
entrepreneur I would love to know from
you which of the seven resonated the
most with you is there an eight nine ten
that I missed that you want to add to
the list leave in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
[Music]
yeah the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would be like a little beacon they
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details